hello wonderful people
um I'm just about to play the first hour
of Kina Bridge of spirits
um going in having not played it so I'll
be totally fresh and if you're new here
it's a game that I've been really
excited to check out because I think the
animation style looks incredible though
I am also interested in it from a
gameplay perspective I'm expecting Zelda
but we'll see but first they actually
look at me a goodie box
a little note that says we are so
excited to celebrate our upcoming
release of Kina Bridge of spirits with
you it truly has been a labor of love
and we hope you enjoy these pieces of
our world and then the first thing in
here
Tina Bridge of spirits man
very very pretty some art I guess let me
move this over to my feet to my chair
okay that should make this a little bit
easier next up oh my gosh
I was gonna say like some more printed
art but oh my God
these are stickers
this is the cutest thing I've ever seen
in my life
oh my gosh
so many what the heck these are
incredible
oh the little Spirits all gonna look
like this in the game
dude okay this one is odd about Benny
and Saya I wonder if they're gonna be
NPCs are a boss fight uh we've got a
couple of these but more characters that
I'm actually gonna avoid reading but
we'll show you guys the odds so that I
don't
spoil any more of this beautiful game
for myself
very cool
and that's going to be our protagonist
we also have I don't know what this is
this little emble lab box of course the
game is made by envelope but I have to
give a huge thank you to for sending
this to me this little guy
little guy oh my God this little
it's wonder if this will be a bottle
opener maybe not a bottle opener
oh teaching lights up very cool this is
gonna be like a necklace or something oh
it's a pin
oh this is also cute we have oh my gosh
oh wow this incredibly cute young man
are you seeing this
this game is already destroyed me the
laser
um like engraved
Tina
gloss that's beautiful Pure Clean
Crystal
Raven Croft Crystal collection wow
but honestly what a lovely package it
just shows how much thought went into
this game and how much love went into
this game from Ember lab so
why don't we jump on over to my PS5 and
stop playing
okay it's time
the menu is even cute
let's do it
abilities recharge when taking damage
enemies are aggressive I mean that's the
normal that's what I generally want to
go with adjust the slider until the
symbol is barely visible if there's a
symbol there I can't see it there we go
I wonder how difficult this game's gonna
be I just assumed it would be easy but
if it ends up having fun hack and slashy
gameplay
combos
unique wooden masks are carved to honor
the dead place in sacred shines he's
must gradually returned to the dust
symbolizing the spirit's peaceful
journey into the next life not all
Spirits can travel this path alone
struggling with tragedies of their past
they linger and become dangerous
monsters called upon to help these
trapped a violent manifestations in my
spirit gods uh thank you for letting me
know that you've updated Marvel
Spider-Man Miles Morales oh
[Music]
I love this kind of world so much love a
forest Spirit got my Totoro tattoo over
here
press L1 to pulse
um
yeah if the game ends up being
challenging then
there might be a good chance that I will
want to replay it
oh that looks lovely
oh my gosh
what a satisfying double jump
wow
that's like beautiful
um
okay
that seems like something you want me to
engage
you do anything
okay okay we got a light attack we got a
heavy attack
I'm picking up what you're putting down
nothing on L2 just yet
Sprint is pretty standard
I can swim
how next gen of you
didn't expect it I've been playing so
many games lately like death Loop and
Psychonauts do what you can't swim but
I'm like caught off guard
I wondered if maybe I could open that
hello my friend
what are you up to
I should play
negative
[Music]
interesting
I feel like they're all peaceful oh
hello there
not a spirit
noticeably not a spirit man
um
okay yeah there you go I didn't know how
to answer that question
oh
that's like um
what happens at any time that you tweet
about anything negative every reply
you know nothing I'm suffering back
spirit to guide oh it's combat time
yeah yeah uh we've been near that
I feel like this should be block
but I don't know if it is okay there is
a lock on system
and then that's your Dodge roll
the Dodge is really good that is um the
one
issue that I have with video game
accessibility is how things often
require like a
double tap of a Dodge and if I have to
press that Circle button too quickly to
get out of the way
I can have a lot of trouble playing any
anything that's fast-paced combat but
this one seems like you just need to
press it once
yeah you can only press it once
beautiful
being that like if you double tap it
doesn't actually do anything
um which is wonderful for me but doesn't
apply to
all games
it seems like a thing where I need to
stand over here again I am so in love
with that oh my
just so pretty okay
oh that didn't do what I expected it to
what's going on over here
is that what I needed to do
specter
so did I just like fight his mates and
then they just kind of left
is that what happened
I feel like so far this Cave System set
of environments does not have as much
detail as I may have expected
but um
who cares
foreign
like they certainly look a little bit
plasticky but I you know what
who cares
this is super pretty this style is
really nice
and I keep wanting to now blue
everything up okay oh that did that did
oh interest
press F to pay respects
how about these ones
is it just floating
and not for gameplay purposes
ah how delightful
you're just gonna have floating flowers
and and and not for collection or
something
my
look at you enriching my world just for
the sake of it that's pretty
that's really cool that'd be a cool
tattoo
I still don't know if I need to do this
but uh here I am doing it
Spirit friend
no this is the two who are not
this really does
just go full Pixar
in the cutscenes huh
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
my heart's just been so warm
oh all right you bullied those kids dog
[ __ ] keys
keys and if I throw yeah we were like 10
minutes through this YouTube video
that'll be fine I can say that
oh
the spirits
oh my
hello young man
what's up with you
[Music]
hi
I think we saw this in the trailer
[Music]
burning noises
oh my gosh
what's wrong with her
have you noticed
[Music]
okay
term a little bit yawning everybody
it is uh pretty late at night I've had
some big work days lately
so for me to fit this in I would have
hoped to have um
had it up on lunch day I know I'm a
little bit late
but uh yeah I've not had a lot of time
lately on cold chilling
um but I have no qualms oh that's fairy
god of Warby
um no qualms with uh
they're playing a wonderful game like
this right before I go to bed
thank you tunnel
oh thanks Disney plus everybody's
getting shout outs today everybody needs
an upgrade huh I guess I just did update
the system I wonder if that was why
this is so nice I
you are most welcome to
set this guy
oh I'm in love with them already
my best friend and we'll be best friends
forever
this is a very Banjo Tooie looking
puzzle or area rather
I should go behind the waterfall
shouldn't I you're gonna let me down in
my lap
you trying to tell me there's nothing
behind here what are you doing
you caught you broke the video game
rules
that's illegal oh there's nothing there
okay can I climb from the water
no
devastating we know
um okay
what did I not do here then
I wonder if maybe I can climb up onto
that
no that's gonna happen later I reckon
this is reminding me a lot more of banjo
than I would have expected so far
ah maybe from here
excellent
behind the waterfall up here is gonna
have the secrets I apologize I called
you out and I was just wrong
you hate to see it
this is a new friend hello
who are you
this is the best thing that's ever
happened to me
um
I'm having a great time
I'm making new friends
I'm very calm
yeah
I feel like I oh well here it is I was
gonna say I expected this game to start
out a little bit more zelda-like where I
expected some kind of terrible thing
that would hurt this peaceful land that
I would have to fix
but this does look very Calamity again
and so maybe this is it
oh no okay I just need to collect more
of the little guys oh oh it'll kill me
oh no
hey little drugs
I'll beat up a kid I don't care
you've watched me
oh
oh yeah sleep box
I paid five dollars for that before we
started the game
I'm super interested
very nice music right now as well
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I was right
I don't think I came through this side
they do glow right they have big big
flowy things
here we go
[Music]
are you telling me
it's baby oh my God
[Music]
your team of companions has grown and
you now have one rot action available
press square to send the rot onto
objects in the environment collect rot
to level up to game of rot actions I
want to sneeze
oh that is them sneezing
[Music]
just thank you for making this you know
what I'm saying um kiss
foreign
[Music]
let's go
clear out
Calamity again and shall we
dude
um
rotten is an interesting name for these
little guys
let me close it to it
why is it making me think so much
of banjo
I really don't know why it feels like
the open area the the beginning area of
banjo
Kazooie or Tui right now
and it's like I'm about to walk into a
series of Worlds of hell and grunty's
gonna be there and I'll get these cool
boots
it really is for some reason
oh thank you my friend oh no I don't did
that wrong
gotta be pretty direct with it that's
all right
I don't know
oh
I brought a scared and I've gone into
hiding attack enemies to build courage
and combat oh that's cute too card shops
can form in the world collect courage
drops of your pulse or touch them to
build a protoster okay
yeah charge that for a bit long I reckon
okay did I get
wrote already they can destroy the dead
so hot okay the ultimate aim and then oh
oops okay um use front on them
individually oh
that's neat
I feel like I'm liking that light attack
a little better right now than that
it's courage there I think
foreign
to take care of
that's what agents do last time
um it's easy to break that combos you
don't have to worry about dodging if you
can
you can get them in one but I guess this
is just starting level enemies
um
I need that too you guys get get to it
my friends
nice walk
again
I love the way they just pop out of thin
air
very cute I wonder how much
environmental variety we'll get here
what are you guys gonna do
rut are really strong oh the rut can
move certain objects in the environment
press
Square to have to pick up an object tell
the right way to go by aiming L2 and
then pressing huh
you guys want to go over there
I think this or will it oh I see I see
it can't go up here
I just assumed that I was supposed to go
up there but maybe it's this way
I don't know where I want you guys to go
yet
[Music]
go one until I figure it out
oh these look cute
foreign
okay
I don't know what it did but I liked it
um alrighty
oh maybe they want me to move it to here
expect so okay
you guys
I need it
here
I'll take a look
see if there's anything else
they're like ants
okay that should do
I would say the jumping doesn't feel
perfect but I think it's because this
animation is so nice that um it doesn't
interrupt the animation is what's
happening
so when you try to grab onto something
it won't do it until she's done with her
lovely little spin jump animation so it
feels a little bit slow potentially
but um can you pick that up oh that's
cute
huh
what should I do with it nothing to just
help him clean out all right cool with
that
um
yeah it is uh
an interesting challenge of what you
want to link together in terms of
animation and what you don't you know
what I'm saying
can I break stuff okay it's not that
Zelda
uh you guys want to get this out of here
it's like I just get to have cute little
friends
um all right
see what I beat it uh that's a really
good example of it there it finishes the
jump before she grabs
um
it just makes it feel a little bit slow
but it looks beautiful I get it oh hello
hello my friend hello good sir how are
you today how are you this fine Eve
let me help you is this the same guy
I can store balance to the forest
I know you are kind
you sense the power that flows through
this land but
you do not fully understand it I like
his accent and his mask
I don't know
craps
oh
land can be healed but you cannot stay
here spirit
you must move on
you are the one who does not belong
he is
much cooler than me slash us I do feel
like maybe we should let him have it
I don't know that
that we can mess with this guy okay
maybe this will be
a tougher fight
okay she doesn't activate that too
quickly
which is definitely
yeah and you can't break up his
animation this is this is this is indeed
oh I can do a proper Parry that was a
proper Ferry
interesting
and he's right
I think I like the light attack a lot oh
oh I didn't even realize he got back up
oh no
I did ask for it I did ask for a
slightly
um more challenging combat why did she
just walk towards me
no okay Jewel since do not do anything
let's do it I'm ready let's go
I didn't realize he stood back up okay
it wasn't fair I was ready to Parry I
was right there and that that happened
okay let's go
yeah let's do it mate
[Music]
I need to figure out what the correct
Parry timing is there it is okay
that was too soon
[Music]
watch for him to
sort his life out
no that's he just does that anyway
yep
I wonder if this is going to be linear
then
oh my God I can watch this all you can
do this as much as you want
keep going
this is gonna be some of the best video
game animation in this kind of world
than anything I've ever seen
oh my gosh
they're just so cute
safe now
look sorry if she cleared away the
poison the little guys can eat it
I just I want to do that so bad I like
little puppies
my name is Cana Cana I've been saying it
wrong this whole time
it's not Kina it is Cana
[Music]
don't worry I can see that you both look
very strong
do you know who that Spirit was with the
horned man if you know who Bella porch
is poach porch boys and girls stronger
famous on Tech talk
which I do not have but still no of her
she talks like Cana does
you take me there it would be very cool
to see her do a video as Cana
because she has this like strange things
she can do as she can speak like she's
animated
uh if you want to get to the mountain
Shrine you'll have to help us with
something first that does sound like a
video game
[Music]
okay great idea that'll be easy for her
did you see what she did to that stick
guy yeah it was pretty cool help us
reach our own we'll take you to lunch I
love his little ego look at him you
helpless free tile I'll take you to the
mountain shrine okay
our village is this way is this gonna be
a village I feel like I remember seeing
that in the trailer as well oh should I
be exploring if I'm on rot I hadn't even
thought about that
that I could probably find them
everywhere right
just gotta look for little white guys
to show up okay nothing here
this is pretty
yeah
gosh
foreign
title card sequence
this is so Zelda it's kakariko
and I love that about it
it doesn't feel like a ripoff or
anything
just like I was inspired by in a way
that um
really lovely
I love the way her role is animated as
well
oh man
because that's like a proper gymnast
role too I did do gymnastics as a kid
and I feel like that's the the correct
foam is that little leap tuck
you
this is not the peaceful place I thought
it would be
really big fan of this design
and the music choices
very chilling
foreign
let's do it
[Music]
so yeah these smaller guys you can
definitely
beat the pants off of
I'm gonna use some rot on that no I'll
be this one
that's a start
there's a lot more to be done huh
still looks pretty messed up anyway
they lose their courage no
if anything happens in combat
let's do it
somebody else gonna try and fight me
oh beautiful
what was it was a Spirit Box over there
that we just saw
a hat caught
what did you say
oh my gosh
great comma by defeating corrupted
enemies restoring the environment
finding fruit for your rot to eat oh
that's what that fruit was they ate it
oh from the upgrade menu cool use comma
to unlock new abilities Cana can approve
her base skills and Infuse her abilities
with brought to create powerful attacks
[Music]
I do feel like this combat is going to
be more involved than I expected
I forward only this one right now whilst
printing press R1 to form a quick
sweeping attack
Don't Mind If I Do
there's a Spirits menu that I can't get
to yet
that's interesting
and a map okay
when did I unlock and then another one
very nice
what is this
what is this what
that's like the stick is I can put hats
on them
you're kidding me how do I do that I've
never wanted to do anything so badly
oh my gosh
oh this is a whole shop
I'm doing it I'm doing that too
oh oh my God game of the year
holy heck
it's gonna be another one and then and
then do you have to buy them is that
guess what's happening oh my
God so yeah like my first impression to
this were like oh my God incredible very
very cute
um very happy to be here but I wasn't
sure
if it would have
the challenge or complexity that I was
hoping for just even based on the intro
which is why you know a lot of games
choose to in that design show you what
all the powers are and then take them
away from you
um like prototype is a really good
example of that you have like a boss
fight where you have all the abilities
and then they take them away from you
and make you slowly level them up
but I feel like this could get pretty
badass
as we continue on okay I guess I should
just go talk to the brothers but oh
was it oh
cool I don't know if they've done that
before
um
yeah I'm thinking that it might end up
having
kind of all the
all the ingredients of a a video game I
really love
all right
so far obviously this combat is is easy
and I would love
to have a bit more of a Parry Dodge
system but that's okay
yeah you really just get to spam and I
will note that I'm spamming
uh one because it doesn't give them
enough time to
um
not you friend
all right what's in the chest is it
another hat
foreign
I will take it
over there what are they gonna do with
it
oh
video games you know
ability to make people happy
ability to make people real sad too
as is art
but also
love a good opportunity to make people
happy oh my God
this makes me want to
go out in the forest
just be in the woods smell some fresh
air
touch some graphs you know what I mean
bestie I just want to touch some grounds
interesting okay
again I recognize I should just go talk
to those boys but
you ain't gonna tell me this world
wasn't designed to be explored
I wasn't sure if I could uh
Traverse the buildings much if at all
doesn't look like it
are these still my road I assume they
are I like how they just um kind of
populate whatever they want to around me
they're always oh I didn't realize it
was there so they're always just kind of
right in front of you wherever you
all right
oh
[Music]
is that another one hello friend join
the club
welcome
killing me okay
cool looking
but I will not
fall for your Temptations just yet my
friend
foreign
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
beautiful
yeah
the rot seemed quite fond of your
usually timid
foreign
something tells me you did not come to
our village looking for Forest creatures
passage to the sacred is everybody a
spirit
our village is bound to the shrine's
energy
but that power faded long ago
that Spirits linger here
Tangled in the tragedies of our past
[Music]
you must help these Spirits if you wish
to reach the mountain shrine
on my way I met two children I suppose I
do for me to help free a boy named taro
I'm not surprised that Benny and Saya
found you
they are clever children
and would do anything is your brother a
babe could there be a romance
crafted wood
I honor those who have passed on
placed here the mask slowly turned to
dust aiding the spirit's journey into
the next life
my father was a spirit
our Traditions are
in this life to the next
so you know what happens to Spirits
unable to move on I do not
take taro's birth
it is bound to his Spirit it will help
you fulfill your promise to the children
oh man these masks are really cool
thank you friend
their brother's fate
it's like giving me Hotline Miami Vibes
so I find it a little bit creepy also
like Bioshock vibes
look through the Moss to find your way
open Spirit Barry's real objects of
importance in the environment Spirit
minds are helpful for finding right
hidden in the world
oh
vasitas
there's something there was that
get out is it here
I was like okay you can't walk when
you're wearing it it's worth noting
what is it
maybe it's in that direction rather than
right there
oh can they go in
oh
not a friend
hey little cutie oh my God the one with
the pot oh my God okay this may kill me
it did
hey you always gotta try you always
gotta give it a try
um all right we'll figure that out later
I think
little mushrooms I'm not hurting anybody
this game is making me very happy
figure that out later it really does
feel like
oh I don't I don't know I just don't
know you know
um what was that oh one or uh
there was some way for me to interact
with those but I now don't remember what
it was
I wonder what if there's anything else
highlighted obviously the chest
another chest over there still I think
that's probably my way point is what
that dot is indicating
um
yeah there was a way for me to use them
I thought
Maybe not maybe I will learn that later
I'm already forgetting the the way it
taught me to use them in combat
just wants me to open that Spirit
barrier huh
ah
that I'd be in control tools options
controls
ah damn you okay
it's okay we can head back
gotta scope everything up
I'm sorry I'm I'm so sure that this is
the least interesting way to watch
somebody play a video game because I'm
doing these videos where I'm like
playing the first hour of stuff on
YouTube lately
and I'm gonna keep doing it because my
first hour of impressions are always so
delighted and observant before I get a
lot more boring
um but I I still you know someone who
doesn't really do let's plays on YouTube
because only just starting to try to do
them more
I'm actively aware that I'm not doing it
the way you're supposed to I'm sorry
about that
okay
you say that but
um only if I have time to explore yeah
[Music]
I also should have gone back to that
that mask shop which I wish I had an NPC
I'll say a nice little cute little NPC
Spirit here would be neat but it's okay
oh oh
okay I can't purchase any anything else
all right
some of the other stuff might have been
stuff I got for
got with the code
yeah I see uh but you know you know what
I'm saying you're just gonna have to
wait you're gonna have to wait
okay
maybe here
[Music]
thank you my friends
oh
Spirit mail you found something that
belonged to a village or return it to
that house in the village the location
is marketing around
okay
that's neat
uh you guys want to help me out and Mac
is going to be here
that's the main quest
Spirit mail delivery is just up the road
is that what that means
pick that back up
it's
this house
[Music]
Maybe
oh it's this
okay
[Music]
well that's neat unexpected
there are a lot more ways to
break through this nonsense than I
expected I think
I'm not worried about you I'm not
worried
you know what as many as you need
I can dance all day like this
Let's Roll
I keep wanting to also press X and then
do it in the air
um
yeah I feel like this game I wish it had
a tiny bit more you know for how
beautiful the animation is
[Music]
um
like a weird thing to say but
interactivity like it does feel like I
should be able to do that in the air
um
a few more ways that the the different
animations could be chained together I
think is what I'm trying to articulate
but obviously still beautiful and a very
good time
[Music]
foreign
I mean maybe I should just leave those
kind of First Impressions out of these
videos and just absorb the world but I
don't know
who's thinking out loud as I play
through really
hello friend would you like to join the
party
we would love to have you oh look at the
little gold guy
[Music]
the mushroom hat one is killing me he's
so cute
the most do
oh
my God
um well I think it wants me to go here
right
maybe not
it actually feels bigger than I expected
it to
they're a lot more like windy side pots
and stuff
don't do that yet
all right you guys what's up I went
through here but we can't get past
there's more of that nasty blocking path
can you get rid of it so we can get I
think I can
leave it to me kids
let's go
you have a
Rock and purify special flowers Crystal
cana's health
send your Rod onto them by pressing
Square okay but this is just a guy with
a shield
he's new
uh where are these flowers you speak of
over there
no
oh
okay step on that that's gonna hurt me
I should investigate that a bit better
oh they can here we go oh I needed the
the courage for them that makes sense
oh rude
quite a good hit
that stuff really does come at your cost
huh
oh that's just another one
um we can probably use the rut on this
now
[Music]
what
bars two temporarily restore the road to
their original form
move the cloud and this film The Rook
can attack enemies destroy barriers and
clear corruption
what
okay the camera's a bit odd
S I agree
uh slams
that's really neat
[Music]
um I think I probably need you guys to
to take this on
being honest
[Music]
okay
let's go guys
nope
[Music]
oh it's just got a timer on it I see I
didn't realize that acrossed
okay Nate
over here okay now there's something in
the ground
um do I have to grow it
there must be something nearby
okay
[Music]
there's blue on everything what are you
well that's cute okay
[Music]
okay I'm gonna we're gonna move this
here I guess
just to see
[Music]
it seems right
it's like the waterfall real quick
don't mind me nothing okay just trade
again
it is what it is
all right
hmm oh
hello there
[Music]
I'm getting like this just a wonderful
sense of Discovery from this game
[Music]
I'm having so much trouble with the
camera
with this this mechanic
let's keep going shall we
didn't have a mark on it I should have
known
that's cool
[Music]
all right
pause trouble
interesting
I do not actually feel the need to do
that but noted
what's up kids
there's more poisonous
cowards I say
yeah
I'm spawning
it'd be cool if when you did that it had
like an area
um impact on uh
the enemies as well so it feels like
they're fighting with you
check out the next one wherever it is
hey
hey Chuck
got that just in time
that one I did not get
ah
a bit of Courage
so I can get some health back
this guy I can't mess me up too bad
nope
oh the rock can do something to him
oh that's right we did know that yeah
oh I should have got that last hit and
there we go
these guys are no concern of mine
heal me my friends
who is this isn't it
perhaps not
beautiful look at us go
all right
yeah it does feel like it helps if Kina
is also Cana is also closer to
close it welcome little guy
truthfully I will take as many of you as
I can get
this way I think would be the right way
this action
oh no oh gosh
come around here we go oh I didn't know
that did that
just get you over here
cleaning for the day has been completed
foreign
oh my God
incredible
I am really loving this music too um
okay why do you want me to go from here
I'm sure if it'll have a waypoint
but I should actually finish playing
right here
this does seem like a good place to stop
before heading
further
um which I think is going to be this way
um this game's beautiful uh which
obviously I expected going in from it um
very excited to see how the gameplay
evolves I feel like I would like to have
more mechanics uh
but right now you know it's so early in
the game that it is really Pleasant and
and pretty and cute and the animation in
those cutscenes is absolutely beautiful
um and I'm so glad to
all these little friends now
oh my gosh
thank you all for watching I will see
you guys next time bye